okay so this is return to the
nightosphere and actually two things we
should mention by the way number one
this camera and the one last week were
different cameras of the quality looks
different I apologize the last one I
don't know what's up with that it was
like cuz that's one of my camera is up
wicking it's like this is a different
setting or something so sorry but that I
don't know how this one's gonna look it
is it looks fine on the small screen
hopefully it looks good on the somewhat
larger screen and the second what's with
the new shirt I never did that like
three episodes in I forgot that what
time's it actually do they ever know
they used to say in the opening rain
it's like what time is it imagine that
but then like they haven't said it while
we have them - it's been a while
okay so we'll remember what Susan strong
to teach you to work a little bit at a
time
incremental time yeah yeah they used to
always have like a different title and
they said they'd serve them yeah I guess
that's fine it's like you talk to force
yourself to do it every single time
no it's just uh finally found another
adventure time shirt no it's like yeah
good we're together uh sweetheart if you
ever want like adventure time
swaggerific just go to Spencer's like
they always have like a whole sections
for the best hot topic that we said my
only problem is it's so expensive
well it's like twenty bucks ten like
fifteen to twenty bucks a shirt is it
yeah well I got this for five well
that's that's a good deal
that's what I'm saying like I don't I
love adventure time but I'm not gonna
run it I got this dispensers well one
though there's a tree trunks like
actually figure one because we want to
have something like thirty bucks or
something Ellie
I like tree trunks but hell no I'm not
doing that that's kind of the thing I
said I love adventure time but I'm not I
can't sit turn we're not bit of money
adventure tad you know bad I can't
justify spending twenty bucks on a
t-shirt you know the the Jake one I got
it as a Christmas gift was that
Christmas or Father's Day I got a script
of Christmas gift I mean
so this little snails from our friend
Christopher he got this for us famous
from Bree her father does Father's Day
right now that's also Christmas this is
from my childhood actually Wow even back
then you're gonna be an adventure time
fan and we've wasted enough of your time
let's talk about return to the
nightosphere before this became the home
shopping adventure time that lovely item
here only five dollars uh wait wait wait
wait wait why are you selling my joke
that sounded much worse than you
probably intended or maybe it's exactly
how you okay this is return the
nightosphere this is the first time we
really see the nightosphere in like kind
of all its glory you haven't paid it's
kind of like The Hangover they wake up
in this really weird predicament they're
in a cage in the middle like this pile
of bananas and they filmed a little bit
on their phone which shows them about to
go to this portal then the battery runs
out and it's just them trying to get to
Marceline's dad who now is a name was a
Hudson Oh God that's an Aberdeen yeah
and which is nice there's only so long
we could say my Salim's dad so as I say
has a name now and so they just want to
go and see him to see what happened to
them and see if they can figure out a
way back it's just a very long extended
road trip pretty much of that of them
trying to get back and they get to UM
he's uh
Marcia's voice now for some reason and
they find the portal they go through and
the Hudsons trying to stop and that
turns out it's not hunt at all it's
Marceline in this costume she says I'm
closing the portal you're never going to
be able to come back you know leave me
alone and closes the portal um
they say they gotta save her but I
didn't I didn't get that vibe I got much
more of a get the hell out I don't want
to see you anymore thing so it's I guess
it's kind of a to be continued they're
saying like they're gonna go back
at the very least figure out what's
going on and I definitely didn't see
that coming I didn't see that now it's
gonna be her um and I am intrigued like
okay well now what's going on well it's
the whole portal thing um but yeah I
think this whole thing is just like a
really cool showcase for the
nightosphere
it looks great like there's this really
long shot just doing nothing but showing
off this world and all the weird
creations and even kind of how it works
in a sense because everything works a
little differently like a guy can get
zapped and he can turn to a bunch of
little versions of himself there's a
cloud that goes around zapping people on
asking questions there there's a river
filled with like people that you find
out is a line as a house the line where
I don't know just serve directs itself
it's I like these I'm just I'm just like
rolling on top of them yeah I like these
worlds where they can kind of create
sort of their own backwards
logic you know and it's so you have to
sort of learn their rules which I like
too but there I know it seems like a
world where it's like yeah these are
different rules but they kind of follow
them too it's I can't explain it like
half the creatures in this are exactly
then actually have creatures like that
one really seem like its sides and could
talk mentally and you're just you're
just kind of earring out how this place
works and everybody's grossed out by the
banana but you don't know why I don't
weird things like that are just sort of
intriguing it makes it seem more like a
real world
whoa which I like there's a lot of like
shows or like movies or what now where
you go to some alternate world where
it's bizarre and strange and that's all
it is yeah it just kind of looks weird
it looks weird everything else operates
like our world it's it's not even that
like this one it's got its own rules in
its laws and everything and if the line
it governs itself you know it's kind of
like that I've seen other things where
like these alternate worlds you go to
our just bizarre for the sake of being
bizarre this one seems to have a little
bit more life behind it there's this
going on here this is going on here but
it's going on kind of for a reason it
seems yeah it's light and it's captured
like even the banan thing like Nana I
don't know why
they're all grossed out by the banal but
you know there's a legit reason it's a
reason everybody understands and it's
kind of the norm there it's just trying
to figure out what that is yeah so it's
like there is a logic it's just trying
to figure out that logic it's got its
own internal logic that it actually
follows and it's bizarre but not just
bizarre for the sake of being bizarre
yeah they're sort of like there is a
rhyme and reason it's just try to figure
out what that rhyme and reason is well
like the guy who's guarding them in the
cellars like well time to everyone out
everyone out there like what are you
talking about well no one else is coming
so and he leaves and then just the
monsters have been imprisoned are just
kind of standing around doing nothing
he's like well maybe these just don't
the smart ones
maybe there's a dummy ones ever do that
again or they seem to be just the dumb
ones so again it's this internal logic
works like that doesn't not gonna go
very far yeah and there's not much
concern about a yeah so it's I yeah so
it's not just the look of the world I
kind of like the actual flow yeah just
sort of the flow and the layout of how
they run things you know even if I don't
fully understand that you can tell they
understand it just you know there's
definitely you know the same way like we
can't always explain everything in our
world like we're what's controversial
what's not like you talking about this
we keep not talking about this or
whatever you know why is this acceptable
why is this not but we kind of know it
and we kind of just got this feel and
sometimes we can explain sometimes we
can't and this world sir feels the same
yeah like everyone just looks at the
finish just like gross it's like you
know can you explain this no it's like
you should know I said oh my god I love
the guy in the boat he's like so uh yeah
I really like this world and I'm glad so
to fire because I really want to go back
to it um like I said just that one long
shot showing off that were
Antonis it's especially long and i love
that because it's like oh just the more
strange creatures and creations they can
show with this like I'm all for it every
every design in this I felt like I was
watching like spirited away or something
or Miyazaki fella just everything is
designed in such a unique cool way yeah
I even that one tall guy like in the
middle of it you know it's like his
mouth has such a weird way and his teeth
are only in the center and his eyes are
kind of sideways that's like every part
of that guy was unique and strange and I
love it actually if he knows his mouth
is a plus
yes are like anything and if you notice
when he talks he's got the 17th here
here but he also has a set of teeth
going this alright on the side - yeah as
awesome I don't like that it's a great
design why what I sort of know is to
watching the Hudson design is that you
know his mouth is sideways too but isn't
just talking like this I realized that
if you look at it kinda this way it like
the lip movements are sort of the same
it's like a normal cartoon characters
lip movements like if it's gonna make it
oh it'll make it oh serve in the middle
of the recipe straight it's just sight
yes so it's not just going like this or
like a sideways muffin edge or the is
forming lip movements it's just to the
side yeah let you know I actually drew
it normally and then just turned it yeah
and that's they don't have to do that I
mean that's just a nice little detail
they throw in there again just - you
don't always notice it but you can kind
of feel it it kind of does rub off those
little details and I've been saying that
kind of since the get-go just it's
always these small things I tend to
notice throughout the series where it's
like they didn't have to actually do
that they didn't have to add that sound
effects effect or that little animation
no one would notice no one would care
but by them doing it it's like that's a
little bit more love and environment to
what's going on yeah it definitely it
makes it feel I mean it is illusion
every time you watch a movie it's an
illusion but it feels more believable
the more and more kind of detail you put
in and the more you can capture the
spirit of what you're trying to to do
there so um yeah I I loved it I thought
was great any other era thought you got
there I just harken back to when you
were on the couch and you said how you
were
now you finally understand why I laughed
at you when you said that it was a long
time coming yeah very very very long
here but now that I am still banana I
will form the Banana Republic and we'll
do something drastic like me close that
she laughed at that yeah because she's a
girl
oh nobody told me
I'm good turn us off because we're gonna
have a very interesting conversation